that man is corey kluber and that man is
towing the slab in the boogie down
brock's on a sunday afternoon michael
there's nothing better than that i wish
i was him
if he wins today's game be his
100th career victory
kluber's ready let's do it here in the
bronx first pitch is grounded to odor
one pitch one out nice way to start for
corey kluber
swing and a miss gets away from
higashiyoka he'll fire the first
strikeout put out two three two down
and the pitch hit on the ground a third
la mahu to field and throw across in
time i guess i'll give you kluber's
numbers later what an inning
i don't think he threw eight pitches in
the inning what a great start jose arena
is uh taking the rubber for the
tigers today and he's looking for his
fourth consistent good outing
ground ball to short that's what we see
after game batter after the batter
that's right knee high bounce for good
run flips over to first he takes care of
his body and he loves to compete this
one driven a deep center field
jones is there shy of the warning track
for a long out and it's all because the
ball moves and sinks down and away hard
on the ground into the shift cut off by
goodram
and the yankees are out in the first
staying off the barrel
swing and a miss
scope down on strikes
big week a couple of good teams
swinging a miss strikeout number three
for clubrous castro goes down look at
the grip that is the classic circle
change grip with a two-seamer spin on it
and kluber's payoff struck him out
swinging
so clover not only struck out the side
but he has four strikeouts in the first
two innings
the winning pitcher
that stays fair it's going to be a base
hit and it rolls and rolls and
it's a fair ball it nipped the bag it
just nipped the bag
so a fortuitous nip
for urchella and he gets himself a base
hit the third so first and third one out
and here is
kyle higashioka
and the pitch
line drive down the left field line it's
a fair ball it goes into the corner
urchella scores hicks is going to third
they're going to hold him up they held
him up at the last moment they throw
behind him and he gets back one-nothing
yanks
now the infield does come up and here's
brett gardner
driven deep to right field grossman back
track wall
and he makes a tremendous catch
tagging his hits he'll score easily on
the sac fly but grossman kept it from
being worse two-nothing angst
swing and a miss
fifth strikeout for corey kluber brings
up robbie grossman the one
in the dirt gets away from higashiyoka
ramos moves up to third and he's in
there safely
now there's the 3-2
struck him out swinging change
so kluber a guy who throws you know hard
hard sinkers hard sliders
the change is working beautifully
looking for a strikeout number seven the
one two
swing and a miss
seven strikeouts in three innings
for corey kluber
so it's more than just one hit per game
here's the one two
off the end of the bat to shallow center
easy play for jacoby jones
the o2 swinging the ground ball on a big
hop to third candelario fields couple of
crow hops an easy flip over to first
right back into that shift sure was
one two three for arena first time the
yankees go in order today
swing and a miss
strikeout number eight
slow roller kluber off the mound fields
over to ford and a one two three inning
cluber has the ball on a string today
there is the one two
hit on the ground to
[Music]
la mayu he throws to first the play goes
five three
the 0-2
tapped slowly right side
oh door
two away
no balls two strikes two ounce pitch
struck him out swinging what a five
innings huh no runs one hit one walk and
nine strikeouts
the two nothing yankees were in the
fifth the two two
swinging a miss he got him with a high
slider the 2-1
swinging to pop up into shallow center
jacoby jones comes in battles the sun
makes the catch for out number two
second trip to the lineup for jose
uranya those are scary moments ball
comes back in a hurry especially after
you deliver it keep it fair
it is fair
and a good inning for jose arena nine
strikeouts and just one walk in five
innings
there's one in that left center there
you go
there's the adjustment too simo cause
that's the same pitch that kluber struck
him on twice on a change up down and
away so here's cabrera he's over two
and that one is chopped to third lemay
you
[Applause]
and that'll do it here in the sixth
inning
you've just got to shut your eyes to the
offense and hope for the best
waving a missed by stanton he strikes
him out to start the sixth
strikes out judge back to back punches
for arena against stanton and judge here
in the sixth
oh door lifts one to right that is 13
yankees set down in a row by jose arena
the tigers are one for ten seven
strikeouts against his change up today
13 swings and misses 0-1
hit on the ground weakly to short
michelle charges fields throws
two-way
0-1 hit on the ground to oh george
second from shallow right throws to
first in time well kluber has just
pitched seven brilliant innings as a
yankee he's given up two hits one walk
and struck out nine you know the biggest
thing he's done give up no runs
the last tiger pitcher to do that was
justin verlander in the middle of the
summer of 2016. say goodbye
to georgella to start the seventh
the 3-2 and he looks at strike three got
the outer third the 2-2 see that and he
struck
struck out forward he didn't like it and
he strikes out the side cliver has come
out for round eight
ramos leads off the eighth inning and he
swings at the first pitch and grounds it
to tyler wade
over to lemayo
popped up
lemayo and foul territory
two-way
pitch
struck him out swinging slider away
what a fabulous game for kluber a
fabulous
a two hit one walk
ten strikeout shutout for eight innings
that'll do
and now we will turn it over to the
yankee closer or aldous chapman and the
o2 pitch
swing and a miss
higashioka gets an angle
over to lemayo
and the tigers are down to their final
out
swing and a miss and that'll do it
chapman with the stare the yankees with
the win is this real life david i i
believe this game is under two hours and
20 minutes